(dramatic orchestral music)
- Imagine you're out in Africa.
It's night-time,
you're sleeping in the
back of an open vehicle,
and it's so hot that
you have no clothes on
and you're still sweating.
All you can hear is the
distant call of a hyena,
and an impala snorting close by,
and you're half asleep
but then your car
just begins to wobble.
You're not quite
sure what's going on,
you tilt your head up,
and you look down
towards your feet,
and all you can make
out is your clothes bag,
sort of on the box next
to where your feet are,
and just all of a
sudden it disappears.
So, quite startled,
and you sit up and grab a torch
and you shine out
into the darkness
and all you can see
is a young male lion
running off into the bush,
carrying all your clothes.
(audience laughs)
I grew up in the bush,
and now as a wildlife
filmmaker I can continue
to spend most of my
time out in the wild.
We choose not to have a camp.
We like to move with animals,
and it keeps us close
to where they are.
We sleep where they are.
It keeps us in touch
with what is going on,
and the filming
vehicles that we've got
are modified for filming.
We like to be able
to see and smell
and hear everything around us.
We wanna be as
unencumbered as possible,
so we cut off the cab,
we take the doors off,
and fold the windscreen down,
and the vehicles are
just completely open.
This little bag
incident that happened,
happened last year to
us while I was in Savute
filming Savage Kingdom,
and it was the young male
lion from the Marsh Pride
that thought it would be
quite funny to sneak in there,
grab my clothes bag
and run off with it.
It was quite a busy night,
you know, as you do,
you jump into the drivers seat,
and you start chasing
after the guy,
and of course you're
completely naked
because now all your
clothes are gone,
and we chased him around
for about 20 minutes
before we managed to
get all my clothes back.
I've actually,
I've still got my bag.
I still take it to the bush.
I still use it.
Quite like this bag,
despite the sort of
holes that he left in it.
I come from a long line
of Botswana bush people.
My Great Grandfather was
one of the first up there.
He was knocking around
all over the place.
He was a hunter.
He got mauled by a
lion at one point
and involved in quite a few
other misadventures, I believe.
My Grandfather who
is that man up there,
he followed my Great
Grandfather into Botswana,
and was given the Okavango
as a hunting concession,
to shoot crocodiles,
specifically.
He was quite an intrepid
guy; a bit of an adventurer.
Spent a lot of time on his own,
and he used to take
little tin boats
and carve his way
into the Delta,
and basically shoot as many
crocs as he could find.
He would go up there
with groups of guys
that would do all the skinning,
and prepare the
skins and salt them,
and get them ready to be
taken back to South Africa
to be exported off to Europe.
But, he lived a wild life
and really explored a
vast part of the Delta
in the mid-50s and early 60s.
He was responsible for killing
probably about 20 thousand crocs
during his time as a hunter,
before he himself was
killed by a Black Mamba.
On one of his hunting trips,
he got bitten and died.
And now of course,
it's completely safe to
swim in the Okavango,
which is not altogether true,
but what it did is gave away to
another generation
of bush people.
My parents then moved
up into the Okavango.
They took over one of
his old hunting camps
and kind of broke the
mold a little bit,
and instead of hunting they
decided to build the first
photographic tourism
camp in the Delta,
and that was in 1967.
A few years later, my
sister and I were born,
and we were born literally into
the bush and into the wild.
The story goes that my
mother had me in Maun,
a small village quite close to,
well, at the base
of the Okavango,
and she figured that it
would be safer to take me
out into the bush than to
leave me in the village.
So, at four days
old she picked me up
and did this long boat journey
up to the camp where
we were living,
and as she arrived at the lodge,
or at the campsite,
she was getting out of the
boat and on to the land
and she didn't want to pass
me on to somebody else.
This is her baby; protect it.
And, climbing out she slipped
and dropped me straight
into the river.
So I was baptized into the
Delta at a very young age.
The life, the next
four or five years,
we grew up,
my sister and I grew
up on this island
out in the middle of the Delta.
My folks used to go into town
maybe once a month at most
to go and get a few
supplies, get a bit of fuel,
and they,
we lived a sort of rural life.
We lived in small reed huts.
You know, we slept on the
floor under mosquito nets,
and you know, bath
time was in the river,
because there were
no crocs at the time,
and in a tin bath
next to the fire.
It was very sort of rudimentary
and a great existence.
My folks used to go
out and catch fish,
and try and subsist
to a large degree.
My mother had a little
vegetable garden
that she used to be at
constant war with the wildlife.
You know, fight
off the porcupines
that were trying to
eat her tomatoes,
or whatever she
was trying to grow.
But essentially,
we sort of lived off the land.
My dad got a POT licence
that he used to have
that he could go and
shoot a few animals,
that he could then
feed his staff
or have food in the camp with.
But that really
wasn't my dad's style.
He didn't really like the
hunting side of things,
and instead he used to
take this little yellow
land rover that we had,
and we'd go out,
track the lions
and find the lions,
and then we'd sit on them
and follow them for hours,
and eventually they
would kill something.
A buffalo, or an impala,
or a kudu or something,
and then he'd use
that little land rover
and push all the
lions off the kill,
help out and cut the leg off,
or a shoulder or
a piece of meat,
and then he would
take that home,
and that's really how we got
most of our food and our meat.
You could imagine as a little
toddler how exciting that was.
That was a grand adventure.
Looking back at how I grew up,
to really sort of,
it looks a little
bit like the Mowgli
and the sort of
Jungle Book story.
It was a wild life.
We grew up surrounded
by predators.
We had lions, hyenas, leopards,
always around us,
and a lot of other
animals that can kill you.
Elephants, hippos, crocs,
and even snakes like the ones
that killed my Grandfather.
Growing up wild like
that sort of gives you
a sense of vulnerability;
you're not top dog.
You're living in a
world full of predators,
and it makes you very
aware and very vigilant,
and you're always very focused
on what is going on around you
and very perceptive
towards the bush,
and I think that's where
my love for the wildlife
and my sort of passion,
and my understanding of the
predator world really started,
began, where it
all stemmed from.
Very soon after,
I left school.
I joined two great people,
which most of you probably know.
Dereck and Beverly Joubert,
they're explorers-in-residence
for National Geographic,
and they lived in the bush
and they lived where
I wanted to be,
and I started an
apprenticeship with them.
Up until this point,
the bush and the wild animals
was really just my life.
It was normal, I was
very familiar with it.
I sort of just moved
through life, you know,
not really appreciating
the upbringing I'd had,
and Dereck and Beverly kind
of shifted that direction
and made me,
they sort of contextualized
the value of my upbringing
and the sort of understanding
that I'd naturally accumulated
by being out there.
They allowed me to look at
nature in a very different way
and in a much more
philosophical way
and really delve deeper into
appreciating these animals
in the natural world.
I was working with
them for about
10, 12 years,
it was the end of that
time I met my wife,
who was at the time having her
own sort of mid-life crisis.
She was giving up her life
as a lawyer in the big city
and decided to move out into
the middle of the bush with me.
So, the two of us we
had a new direction
and a new purpose,
and we were determined
that we were going to live
and stay out in the bush,
and as it happens,
not long after we did that
we had some children,
and we weren't going
to let that stop us.
So we moved everybody
out into the bush
and we decided to
live out there.
We both really believe that
it's a gift to grow up wild,
grow up in the bush,
and we wanted to,
we had an opportunity to
give that to our children.
So, we're hell-bent
on staying out there.
We could slowly teach
them about tracking,
about the signs of the wild.
We could teach them about
how the bigger animals,
the scarier animals,
are often the more
gentle animals.
We wanted them to grow up strong
and have this intrinsic
sense of nature and animals
sort of embed into them
at a very very young age.
Let them develop their own
intrinsic understanding
and compassion
towards the wildlife.
And luckily,
those tin baths didn't evolve
much in 25 years though.
Very useful.
It's amazing how
we so often follow the
path of our parents.
This picture was taken in 1979;
that's my sister and myself
getting a few lessons in life
right out in the
middle of the Okavango,
and this picture was taken
just over a year ago.
Andy took the picture.
We're out there with our family,
living the wild life.
Being out there in the bush,
just in a totally
different location.